le ton est donné pour le dernier tour
des élections législatives en france
c'est à cette étape qu'on saura si la
coalition ensemble du président emmanuel
macron conservera sa majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale il lui faudrait
289 sièges pour mener sa politique de
réformes dont celle des retraites nous
sommes la seule force politique en
mesure d'obtenir la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale face à la
situation du monde et à la guerre aux
portes de l'europe nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le risque de l'instabilité et
des approximations
aussitôt les résultats préliminaires
annoncés celui qui talonne la coalition
présidentielle affirmé que le parti des
manuels macron a été battue et des faits
jean les pelles un champ en a profité
pour lancer un appel aux électeurs pour
la première fois de la vème république
un président nouvellement élu ne
parvient pas à réunir une majorité à
l'élection législative qui suivent pour
nos vies personnelles et pour le destin
de la patrie commune
j'appelle notre peuple
a déferlé dimanche prochain les
élections législatives ont mis en
lumière l'effondrement de la droite
traditionnelle et la forte progression
du parti d'extrême droite de marine le
pen qui arrive troisième avec 17% des
voix il est important de ne pas laisser
emmanuel macron disposer d'une majorité
absolue dont il amusera pour appliquer
ces méthodes autocentré et brutale que
les électeurs soient de droite ou de
gauche une question demeure seront
celles plus nombreux au deuxième tour un
français sur deux a boudé les urnes une
abstention record
je trouve ça vraiment dommage qui vient
au taux d'abstention
aussi élevé parce que lors des
présidentielles il y avait une assez
forte mobilisation car là j'avais fait
la queue pendant une heure
là y'avait personne je sais pas trop ce
que j'espère je sais juste que ces
arbres voire d'aller voter le second
tour aura lieu dimanche prochain si la
gauche de jean luc mélenchon devait
l'emporter elle imposerait une
cohabitation inédite avec le président
macron fraîchement réélu autre enjeu
d'importance pour le locataire de
l'elysée le résultat final pourrait
influer sur la composition du
gouvernement puisque 15 ministres dont
la première ministre et les à bedford
son candidat en cas de défaite ils
devront démissionner chantal leblond
radio canada montréal